إذن ، ما الذي أعطاك هذه الفكرة بالتحديد
للسفر عبر إفريقيا
أم لزيادة الوعي بالأشخاص
الذين يعيشون هناك مع مرض باركنسون ، يعود
الأمر بعيدًا في الواقع ، كنت أرغب دائمًا
في القيام بهذه الرحلة
منذ أن انضممت إلى الجيش في الواقع
تمامًا كما كان من قبل.  لقد كان دائمًا
شيئًا كان في ذهني
،
ولن أترك حالتي الخاصة
تمنعني من القيام بذلك ، وقد
خلق ذلك بالفعل الدافع
لجعل الرحلة تحدث من الواضح أنه
لا يوجد علاج لمرض باركنسون وأنت تعلم أن
هناك الكثير  من الأماكن والمدن
والبلدات في جميع أنحاء إفريقيا حيث
لا يتمكن الأشخاص من الوصول إلى طبيب أعصاب ،
ما هو نوع التأثير الملموس الذي
تعتقد أنه
يمكنك القيام به في هذه الرحلة ، فأنت تعرف عندما
تتحدث إلى الناس وبينما تسعى
إلى زيادة الوعي
لن أكون قادرًا على إخراج أطباء أعصاب
من القبعة أو إنتاج الكثير من الأدوية
أو أي شيء من هذا القبيل ، لكن ما سأكون
قادرًا على فعله هو
زيادة الوعي بما يشبه ليس
فقط بالنسبة لي
ولكن لأولئك الأشخاص الذين أقابلهم.
طريقة وصف
حالتهم الخاصة وجعل الناس أكثر وعيًا
بما يمرون به
لأن أي شخص مصاب بمرض باركنسون
يعرف ما يشبه أي شخص يعيش
مع الأشخاص المصابين بمرض باركنسون لديه
فكرة عما يبدو عليه الأمر ولكن لديه في
الواقع و  أن
تعاني من عواقب
الأدوية السيئة ، فإن
الأعداد القليلة من أطباء الأعصاب ، إلخ ، تجعل
الحياة أكثر صعوبة بشكل كبير ،
وإثارة هذه المشكلة للجميع هو
أمر بالغ الأهمية في حالتي ،
أعني أن الكثير من الأشخاص الذين تعرفهم يعتقدون
أنهم يفهمون أنك تعرف ما
هو مرض باركنسون في الواقع و  كيف
يبدو التعايش معها ، لكنني شعرت
بالدهشة حقًا عندما شاهدت مقطع الفيديو هذا
الذي تتحدث فيه عن
الوحدة والعزلة وحقًا عن مشاعر عدم
القيمة
التي تشعر بها على أساس يومي
لأولئك الأشخاص الذين يشاهدون الأشخاص الذين يفرزون
يعرفون القليل عن الأساسيات حول
هذا المرض ولكن لا يفهمون
حقًا عاطفيًا ما يشبه
التعايش مع هذا ، ما الذي ستفهمه  y
blimey شاهد الفيلم وشاهد هذا الفيلم
الوثائقي ، سأقوم
بعمل أكبر شيء منفرد
فيه هو أن هناك الكثير مما
لا
يعرفه الناس عن المشاكل الحركية
وتعثر
الأزرار في
الكتابة  مراوغة كل هذا النوع من الأشياء
التي تكون مهينة للغاية ولكنها
عواقبها على الطريقة
التي تعيش بها حياتك وأنت بصراحة
تجعلك ترغب في التسلق
وقطع كل اتصالاتك مع الأشخاص الذين
تحبهم في بعض الأحيان تقريبًا لأنه صعب جدًا